I do want to congratulate you you're
writing a memoir which is so exciting
like you forgot for a sec I know I did I
did so many other things that I'm I'm
like wow that's right
yes how how emotional was the experience
of putting pen to paper and reliving all
of those memories it was so emotional
honestly cuz it's like you remember your
life before everything happened and then
fast forward you know during the years
of the group and everything you know
experience and stuff and then now it's
it's amazing and sometimes you know when
I'm writing it's very like I put my mind
back to that time and it's like whoa
okay dad I make it out of it you're not
there anymore but he get a little
emotional in the moment for sure there
have been moments where I've definitely
definitely teared up writing you know
because there's so many amazing things
that happen and so many hard times that
I've experienced and hurdles I had to
get through but it's all so exciting for
me to put that to pen paper and make
everything my own in my words and
ultimately I hope to uplift people
through my story we're gonna say what's
the goal what do you want readers to
feel as they're going through the pages
I want them to feel like they're going
through what I'm going through and all
the good and the bad and also ultimately
I want to just portray my story to the
world I feel like people know me but
they don't really know me and they don't
know exactly and they don't know me
before you know the group and its
success and and why I am Who I am and
that's gonna be really really important
I touch on a lot doesn't everything we
hear the word memoir we're wondering
humming them how much tea are you
spilling yeah that's me bombshell it's
gonna be great it's gonna be great I
can't wait in the spirit of the holidays
everyone wants to know have you talked
to the girls have you wished him happy
holidays yeah I mean I know we're all
really busy right now but we me and
Dinah were jamming reading last week I
blues time but yes so I know everyone
can outdo each other songs she just put
something sure yes that's right she is
freaking
killing it she looks amazing and
smelling beautiful and everybody else is
just like it's crazy it's amazing to see
everybody do their thing I love like
Fang I think it's it's just everybody is
just so freaking beautiful and talented
and it's insane
speaking of talent Allie Brooks spent
time with the next generation of young
stars when she made a surprise
appearance at a local la high school
[Applause]
the pop star sang three songs before
hanging out with the kids who received a
generous donation thanks to StubHub and
the mr. Holland's Opus foundation today
seventy seven thousand dollars worth of
instruments right here are going to the
kids at this high school so they can
achieve their dreams I know dreams that
you had as a kid
yeah what does it mean to you to see
these kids being able to participate in
music programs I know something that you
probably really relied on as a kid
absolutely it is so important it's
imperative because this really shapes
you and it shapes your creativity and
you're able to learn and experiment and
try something new and through music
nothing gets better than music and for
the kids actually have an outlet and
again to be encouraged to do so is
something that's so incredible you never
know you could see the next like John
Legend come out of here or the next you
know next alley Brook come on trouble be
good be kind to each other we need it
now more than ever I believe in you all
god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]